my spiced bait porridge absolutely loved
it
why I grew up with it there's something
very Scottish about porridge is that
kind of sort of great start to the day
my father used to say porridge needs
salt and so only it separates the men
from the boys
didn't really like it it was assisted
sole puts hairs on it I used to sneak a
couple of sugar lumps from cafes and put
them in my porridge without and watching
these days my porridge has much more
flavor than just salt it's packed with
fruit nuts and spices add vanilla seeds
to porridge oats or oatmeal really
important just to rub the vanilla
through the oatmeal makes it nice and
fragrant now a little teaspoon of
cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg already that smells incredible I
quite like making this up week at a time
and Jack absolutely loves it
now whole almonds now if you don't like
that kind of crunch running through the
porridge you can chop these up or blend
them to a powder but I quite like this
little texture hazelnuts incredibly good
they're really nice crunch keep your
vanilla pod in there as well that just
gives it even more lift and of course
wants his bait just pull it out instead
of sugar I'm adding sweetness with fruit
fresh pears and raisins cranberries are
great as well
chopped apricots as well dried apricots
in the side mango
I love dried fruit next pour in a pint
of milk and mix this can be done the
night before left in the fridge and then
cut them in before you got to bake it
add your cream now into your dish it
looks quite liquid but by the time it
bakes has this really nice rich crust on
top and then just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out
sprinkle on Demerara sugar and grill to
create a sweet golden crust a sort of
glaze on top beautiful
literally for three to four minutes
[Music]
look at that that makes me feel proud to
be Scottish because it's perfect for a
big comfort family breakfast is rich is
sumptuous and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit it's a bowl full of love
to start the day
[Music]